I didn't know it was gonna be a big deal
I was just trying to make something to
sound cool you know it's like when
artists talk about all they made like a
song in 20 minutes and they didn't know
and then it becomes like the biggest hit
of their career like I hope the animal
is not the biggest head of my career but
so far it's like top three my name is
Cypress sounds hip-hop DJ from New York
City and I popularized the air horn
sound effect into a global phenomenon
yes Jamaica in the late 70s early 80s
used to have these parties and within
these clubs which they called dance
halls and in that moment everyone gets
excited they scream and make noises and
they would hit air horns and then it got
to a point where DJ started having
little samplers and have it playing it
himself
dancehall and hip-hop are basically like
path letters DJs especially Kool Herc
lose Jamaica move to to the Bronx and
with throw these parties like you used
to grow in Jamaica the whole scene moved
here and that's what created his back so
early 2000s around 2001 2002 I got my
own show on hot 97 cypher Saturdays and
I wanted to sound different than all the
other DJs so I would use the air horn
and a couple other Jamaican sound
effects let's see it was hard it was
hard to play sound effects like that
back in the day cuz you didn't live in a
club you would hit the air horn forever
ever ever ever and it'd be different I
guess like rhythmic variations of how we
play so we couldn't do that in the
computer so I had to like make my own
version so I would just hit the button
once but it would play like it was live
which is the one that kind of like
exploded I didn't invent the air horn
sound I didn't invent the usage of it
and a party me being on the radio I just
became the guy knows
[Music]
[Music]